you'll never find me
we'll see about that um
i yeah you're never going to find
marquis that's the best hiding spot in
the entire universe
i know not so high i know what the
hotter they just start don't give them
clues i have to say
okay give us a clue okay
all right look under the overly arching
place you would find
that i'm bigger than a bread box outside
of your house
my mind just got blown right there i
know i'd say
pretty hot if someone wouldn't i've
heard that before
wait i'm barely there
shoot that explodey barrel i can see you
shoot things
don't shut him oh god that hurt oh god
where is he where the [ __ ] is he we just
just go real close to all the explosive
barrels and shoot him
that's this is like that office map we
played the other day and you just
trolled the [ __ ] out
oh god it's supposed to be you don't god
i don't want that one
there's so many props he's this one here
no i'm not
how did you know i wasn't doing damage
when i shot him
oh [ __ ] mario i'm on your team why did i
do that i forgot i'm so sorry
you don't want to be on my team all
right i i didn't know i was
yeah oh you were helping him get i got
to get yeah whatever pink
mustache of course i want to be in your
team
no you're your your icon is the stuff of
nightmares but that's okay
i i [ __ ] pewdiepie oh
god bad you know a bad yammy mash in me
shipping like markimash has gotten like
people
have been i get fan art of just gay porn
of both of us
every day you don't want that no what
the hell are you guys been doing exactly
and you're
nothing i've been doing nothing
felix in the last tt tv
were talking about getting divorced
where are we i don't remember that
i was editing it yesterday on this thing
to you
i heard it okay all right why is
everything so shiny in here
yeah i know it's like you can see the
galaxy in there huh thanks there
it's awesome oh [ __ ] sorry i didn't see
anything this might have been big what
the hell
oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh
oh oh oh
i had you i had your back i was
following felix and it kind of backfired
there's so much stuff follow me mark
where where where
where'd you go i don't know okay
i'm i'm i'm
uh-oh i gotta stay here you go without
me no i'll help you
all right oh [ __ ] i fell down i'll come
for you mark
uh you might not want to do that hey
it fell down from something
wait they might be both being here no
they're not right
oh my god okay what
what'd you do i couldn't handle it
apparently
mark yes
i'm right there right there i really
like the encouragement beauty that was
you really helped me out there
um let's do something let's do something
hilariously comic together follow me
i've actually got a plan this might work
really
it's not gonna work okay don't don't
okay
i'm here no not that that's a really bad
idea
oh actually no yeah you you do that and
i'll do this okay
i got your plan here i got your plan
right here
you want to see my plan what is the plan
you want to see my plan
oh what did you do i thought
i thought they would be nearby that
would have been awesome if you did it
though
yeah if that would have worked that
would have been so cool all right
the warehouse is pretty cool inside i do
like it it's pretty cool yeah nice
lies i don't trust this
i don't fall for your tricks you dirty
dirty
props
keep running keep running
oh my god oh my god okay what the [ __ ]
didn't you see us oh my god
what the [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah are they messing
with you or me
i think they're messing with us both
all right what are you doing i like
being pulled along by this train
yeah over here okay oh god i can't make
it though
sounds really perverted when you're
saying that
oh
went there
where's the guy going huh
where are you
stop it stop it stop it stop laughing
okay all right what the [ __ ]
i don't like your attitude oh i wait
till you stop playing with the barrels
and swap to one of them but then you
came back and played with them again
really yeah
mark
[ __ ] is that you maybe [ __ ] what
what happened to you i've i got a little
fat put on a little weight
what's your favorite snack food mark oh
it used to be cheeses until my fans sent
me like a hundred boxes
oh my god with the face of cheez-its
okay it apparently am
no she's just contacted me they actually
did they asked me yeah but i didn't take
it because
i don't know why dumb who doesn't want
i don't even know what it is it's like a
whatsapp cheese nips
do you have cheese nips over there oh
nips i love nipples
yeah well uh yeah what wow wow
are you okay yeah things blew up but
it's okay
are you alive mark yes where are you i
i must say i saw like um
i saw a montage of ttt i saw one i saw
one move
i said
there you are i was trying to distract
felix was under the car but he's not i
think he's long gone
yeah he was there i saw him
what are you doing you're kidding he's
kidding cheating here
over here oh yeah yeah yeah that's what
i was gonna say and then then they
yeah exactly you know what i mean yeah
what
i don't like where this is going stop
talking in the bridge oh this is a bad
idea now
how much time do we have no nine seconds
three hours you're fine
all right you're gaming yeah i'm playing
i think this is a really bad idea though
where are you where
are you wait wait i found them
you did where they're right here
what the [ __ ] it actually won't
talk about it
okay um will you guys we're gonna play
hot and cold with them
all right hong kong oh very cold cold
cold
cold cold cold called
one more person carrying the barrel that
you're really warm
oh person who dropped the barrel is
really warm
first no near you oh i can't believe
you're actually at that angle
i don't think you actually could be on
your side but that's quite impressive
what the [ __ ] are you looking at
it's [ __ ] rolling and you guys can't
even see it no
that's a lie how can a barrel roll
without
all right i'll keep a lookout over here
i'll make the eagle sound if i see
anyone again
what's the eagle sound sound like
in the in the case of a real sighting
the eagle sound will be much more
slightly warm you're both slightly warm
and he just played you both like a
[ __ ] fiddle and jesus christ
lies lies if i'd if anything had
happened my eagle eyes would have seen
there's no way you could have escaped
what are you laughing at i'm not going
to tell them because that was just
beautiful that was just the beautifulest
thing i've ever seen
i don't know stop
lying jesus christ
oh my god guys oh my god shut up
shut up
wait i have an idea they saw that they
saw that man
i was on top of him
wait let me ride you and i won't kill
you okay
go oh [ __ ]
how did you do that he was gonna
see anything he was moving round and
round the van when you guys weren't
looking at that
he's lying don't listen to it i don't
think so i cannot
hear where
where i know the perfect spot
ah where are you oh you're looking fast
and hot i like it
hey stop it you don't make fun of me
because
what the [ __ ] am i i'm stuck [ __ ]
there's nothing
no i can't help you me or something
there's nothing i can do for you
it was not the damn thing oh hi pewds
hey
what the hell do we do that we're free
oh no where are you where do you go
how they are a beautiful fat man thank
you i'll be the same as you we'll be fat
together
what how do i get out of my fat form i
don't know
wait let me let me touch you okay i have
no idea
wait what what is going on the hell are
you not
hi mark what are you how do you see me
no i see you what is that that is the
current cranium
yes yeah okay okay mark he's a friend
mike let's go yes okay sorry right now
don't
try it plan b plan b
he's over here
hey i saw something
run what happened
they were the smallest things in the
world what was that like a toilet
fixture thing
i don't know it was tiny
was it i i don't know what it was it
could have been
it could have been a lot of things use
your imagination
and you could you can have anything
could it have been a dildo
that's very rude i would never make such
a joke in any of my videos and i find
that quite
vulgar that's offensive unsubscribing i
lost all respect for
have you changed since you hit a million
subs
as soon as this video comes out back to
a hundred thousand oh why
you swallow a [ __ ]
wait wait wait what why you see this
what yeah you see it
yeah do you like it where are you
nice hole i don't know where i am i
don't know where you are um and i don't
really want to give myself away
i'm going to be back on my perch again
if i see anything
i can't say you're moving all right i'll
drive the car
oops i i used my grenade
that actually hit me when did you shoot
it
why did you shot over by that thing
right there
that thing that thing yeah yeah i have
four i'm lucky i have like 50 health
otherwise i've just been [ __ ] then
let's be honest yeah
you got nothing
the system works none shall escape my
gaze
all right you are the hawk yeah yes
makes
i don't know where you are oh wait yes i
do i think i do
you can just left click and you'll be on
me yeah
i see i see you see what do you see
i actually changed props to get some
health back fortunately oh you can do
that that's true
that's okay there's two big ones so i
was okay
interesting really very
interesting really give me a good time
there in the
in the garage bowling
i love ballin it's my favorite
don't you guys like bowling where did
you go
what what are you laughing at what are
you laughing at
i don't like it i don't like when they
laugh mark i love being a green van it
makes my day
what what
she's got a lot of health
oh my god look i'm not it's bleeding you
almost got it
what it is bleeding it is bleeding why
is it bleeding
it must be her
nice mix
how about a clue you've been i've been
watching you the whole time and you've
been walking
past me very a lot okay okay very a lot
okay
very well he's inside the the warehouse
thing
or the mechanic garage okay i know where
she is
i know where she is that was just i know
what she is
i don't know i know where she is
somebody
somebody was very very close to her i
know it's just i know it's just
do you know oh [ __ ] oh my god
i know it's just i know [ __ ] she's no
longer
inside the crash damn it oh god damn it
i'm going back on my perch
i know where she is i know where she is
okay she's inside of something while we
all are
god damn it where i know where she's oh
no
okay she's inside the garage the grass
is that true i swear i'm all right i'll
watch the entrance you go in
okay watch out she might kill you my ass
i got it i am all over your ass she's
back in hiding
okay wait something was rolling
ah hey chad how are you doing
where'd you go why did
no i don't even kn don't fight me
i wonder how many people they got into
the studio
well that doesn't make any sense guy
what do you need that for them
yeah and they're like oh yeah